Hey guys, it's Jeff Meacham.
大家好，我是杰夫·米查姆。
I played the wedding DJ in the season three finale.
我在第三季结局中扮演婚礼 DJ。
I believe it was 2007.
我相信那是2007年。
I had just moved to Los Angeles.
我刚刚搬到洛杉矶。
It was the second job I ever booked out in LA.
这是我在洛杉矶预订的第二份工作。
First comedy, I had booked first multi-cam.
第一部喜剧，我预订了第一个多机位。
And as soon as I got onto set, I was like, oh, this is what I want to do for the rest of my life.
当我一进入片场，我就想，哦，这就是我余生想做的事情。
And here's why.
原因如下。
We get onto set.
我们进入片场。
It's this wedding set.
就是这套婚纱照。
There's a lot of background.
有很多背景。
There's all sorts of moving parts.
有各种各样的活动部件。
And I'm up in the kind of a bird's eye.
我就像鸟瞰一样。
to you in the DJ booth and boom, first team comes in and you guys are all carrying your coffees and your sides and your cracking jokes and having the best time together and Pam comes in and kind of orchestrates the whole scene.
DJ 台上的音乐响起，第一支队伍进来了，你们都端着咖啡、配菜和笑话，一起度过了最美好的时光，帕姆进来了，安排了整个场景。
Neil's character comes and stands next to me and then you guys were hers and someone just yells the word suck a team and you guys just kind of funnel off together, leave, grab your coffees and you're giggling as you're leaving an income to this group of people that kind of look like you, wearing chalkboards with your character's names on them.
尼尔扮演的角色走过来站在我旁边，然后你们就是她的了，有人大喊“烂队”这个词，你们就聚在一起，离开，喝杯咖啡，一边咯咯地笑，一边给这群看起来像你的人留下收入，戴着写有你角色名字的黑板。
And I was like, what is this?
我当时想，这是什么？
And somebody comes over and they're like, oh yeah, yeah.
有人走过来，他们说，哦，是的，是的。
They basically come in rehearsing and then they leave and they get to go have the best time of their lives.
他们基本上是排练然后离开，然后开始享受一生中最美好的时光。
Well, these people come in and do all the blocking and get everything set with the lights.
好吧，这些人进来，做所有的阻挡工作，并把一切都设置好灯光。
And then they come back in and tell jokes and be stars.
然后他们回来讲笑话并成为明星。
And I was like, oh, that's what I want to do for the rest of my life.
我当时想，哦，这就是我余生想做的事。
So that really was a big turning point in my life where I was like, oh, this is amazing.
所以这确实是我人生中的一个重大转折点，我当时想，哦，这太棒了。
I remember that.
我记得。
I remember how kind Pam was.
我记得帕姆是多么友善。
In fact, I just got to work with her again recently, and how cool it was as this young 20-something where Neil comes over and stands next to me.
事实上，我最近刚刚再次与她合作，作为一个 20 多岁的年轻女孩，尼尔走过来站在我旁边，这真是太酷了。
I was like, hey, man, I grew up watching you.
我当时想，嘿，伙计，我是看着你长大的。
You're amazing.
你太棒了。
And he's like, thanks.
他说，谢谢。
I was like, oh, also, do you remember on Law & Order a couple of years ago where you played that kind of psycho killer guy where you lobotomized women by pouring hot water into their brains?
我当时想，哦，还有，你还记得几年前在《法律与秩序》中，你扮演了那种变态杀手，通过将热水倒入女性的大脑来对她们进行脑白质切除术吗？
And he was like, yeah, I was like, my wife was that woman.
他说，是的，我说，我的妻子就是那个女人。
And he was like, cool, I was like, cool.
他就像，酷，我就像，酷。
So there you go.
所以就这样吧。
incredible show to be on.
令人难以置信的表演即将上演。
You guys were the best and I can't thank you enough for that experience.
你们是最棒的，我对你们的经历感激不尽。
Well, thank you, Jeff.
好吧，谢谢你，杰夫。
What a great note to start the show with and what a voice he has.
节目的开头真是太好了，他的声音也很棒。
I hope he has his own podcast, right?
我希望他有自己的播客，对吗？
Let's get a little voice.
让我们发出一点声音。
Alec has done podcasts with Jeff, right?
亚历克和杰夫一起做过播客，对吧？
Their buddies.
他们的伙伴。
Oh, Jeff.
哦，杰夫。
Yes, Jeff.
是的，杰夫。
And I have a podcast that's meeting Tom Cruise.
我有一个与汤姆·克鲁斯会面的播客。
if you can go listen to that too.
如果你也可以去听听的话。
Yeah, that's awesome, that's a great story, Jeff.
是的，那太棒了，这是一个很棒的故事，杰夫。
I'm so glad that I didn't know that little bit you did, being in that one episode, this episode, something borrowed, meant so much to you and it was such an early part of your journey.
我很高兴我不知道你做了那么一点点，在那一集中，这一集，借来的东西，对你来说意义重大，这是你旅程的早期部分。
That's one of the many things, you don't know, you don't know what it means in the moment.
这是众多事情之一，你不知道，你不知道那一刻意味着什么。
It's good to, when you're starting out in a business as crazy and unpredictable, as the one we're in, it's really good to have good early formative experiences, where you see functional working set, where people are happy, it's fun to tell stories, It's fun to be there, so we're glad we were able to provide that.
当你刚开始从事像我们这样疯狂和不可预测的业务时，拥有良好的早期形成性经验真的很好，你可以看到功能齐全的工作环境，人们很高兴，讲故事很有趣，在那里很有趣，所以我们很高兴能够提供这些。
They're not all like that.
他们并不都是这样。
Not every set is like that, and yeah, that's cool.
并不是每组都是这样，是的，这很酷。
Thank you.
谢谢。
Well, we're thrilled you could join us, and we're thrilled you who are listening to this could join us here today for another episode of How We Made Your Mother, where Craig Thomas and I talk about the TV show we made together or How I Met Your Mother.
好吧，我们很高兴您能加入我们，我们很高兴正在收听此节目的您今天可以加入我们的另一集《我们如何创造了你的母亲》，其中克雷格·托马斯和我谈论了我们一起制作的电视节目《我如何遇见你的母亲》。
I played Ted Mosby on that show from 2005 to 2014.
2005 年至 2014 年我在那部剧中扮演泰德·莫斯比 (Ted Mosby)。
Craig and his buddy Carter Bayes co-created the show.
克雷格和他的好友卡特·贝叶斯共同创作了该剧。
We did 208 episodes of the show, and we are barreling through watching them all again.
我们已经把这部剧看了 208 集，现在我们正在快速地把它们全部看完。
And we're coming to the end of season two.
第二季即将结束。
How is it possible?
怎么可能呢？
It's incredible.
太不可思议了。
Today we're talking about episode 21, something borrowed written by Greg Malins, one of our faves who was on the show a couple episodes ago this season.
今天我们要讨论的是第 21 集，这是我们最喜欢的人之一格雷格·马林斯 (Greg Malins) 借来的，他在本季前几集就出现过。
Now, Alec, tell us historically root us.
现在，亚历克，告诉我们历史上的根基。
When was this, when did this episode air?
这是什么时候的事，这集是什么时候播出的？
Yeah, cast your mind back to May 7th, 2007.
是的，让你的思绪回到 2007 年 5 月 7 日。
Wow.
哇。
It's a TV wedding, so it happened in May sweeps.
这是一场电视婚礼，所以它发生在五月份。
We could have guessed May.
我们本来可以猜到梅。
May was, May would have been the top most, that would have been number one on the Family Feud guesses.
梅是，梅会是最重要的，这将是家庭世仇猜测中的第一名。
Yeah, that's, that's crazy, man.
是的，这太疯狂了，伙计。
This is a good one.
这是一件好事。
This begins, this is kind of part one of a two-parter.
这就是开始，这是两人的第一部分。
And Josh actually said earlier today, like it's kind of part two of a three-parter because it feels like the episode showdown that proceeds this has a few little nuggets planted in it about the wedding.
乔什今天早些时候确实说过，这就像三部曲的第二部分，因为感觉接下来的剧集对决中埋下了一些关于婚礼的小金块。
You actually get a little glimpse of this wedding, Marshall's in a hat in the wedding very mysteriously.
你实际上可以瞥见这场婚礼，马歇尔在婚礼上戴着帽子，非常神秘。
Marshall's in a hat, which is great.
马歇尔戴着帽子，这太棒了。
It led Jordana to say, why is Marshall wearing a hat?
这让乔丹娜说，为什么马歇尔戴着帽子？
In that weird hat, you know, wait for it?
戴着那顶奇怪的帽子，你知道，等等？
Yeah, and also isn't showdown where Ted and Robin come in and their spaghetti stained clothes?
是的，泰德和罗宾的衣服也被弄脏了，这不是摊牌吗？
Yes, yes.
是的，是的。
They come in and they're covered in spaghetti sauce and they say, we'll tell you that later.
他们进来时，身上沾满了意大利面酱，他们说，我们稍后再告诉你。
And they mean it, they mean much later because you don't find out until the episode after this, but that's why these three feel like a three part finale in a way of the season.
他们是认真的，他们的意思是很久以后，因为你直到这一集之后才发现，但这就是为什么这三部感觉像是本季的三部分结局。
Well again, it's mysteries.
好吧，这又是个谜。
It's little mysteries woven throughout.
这是贯穿始终的小谜团。
But it also shows to me that you guys were really mapping this thing out and you were really, you wanted everything to count.
但这也向我表明，你们确实在规划这件事，并且你们真的希望一切都重要。
You know, sometimes there's dangling threads or people comment and say, why did this happen?
你知道，有时会有悬而未决的线索或人们评论说，为什么会发生这种情况？
because in episode, you know, season seven, this happened, and you couldn't account for everything, but I think you guys did an amazing job tying things up and...
因为在第七季中，这件事发生了，你无法解释一切，但我认为你们在把事情联系起来方面做得非常出色......
Thank you.
谢谢。
Yeah, we took it seriously.
是的，我们很认真地对待它。
I was very excited because my wife hadn't seen this one a long time and I said, do you, well, I guess it was in showdown, I said this, I said, do you remember why they're covered in pasta sauce?
我很兴奋，因为我的妻子已经很长时间没有看到这个了，我说，你知道吗，好吧，我猜这是在摊牌，我说这个，我说，你还记得为什么他们被意大利面酱覆盖吗？
And she's like, no, it didn't register for her at all.
她说，不，这根本不适合她。
And she was like, she didn't think it was weird, it just kind of goes by.
她觉得，她并不觉得这有什么奇怪的，一切就这样过去了。
Yeah.
是的。
And then like when we watched, we watched the spoilers, We watched the one we're talking about after this, which is something blue, the finale of season two, and it paid off, and she was very excited, because she was like, that's the pasta sauce.
然后就像我们看的时候一样，我们看了剧透，我们看了之后我们正在谈论的那个，那是蓝色的东西，第二季的结局，它得到了回报，她非常兴奋，因为她说，那就是意大利面酱。
Okay, now I got it, she completely forgotten.
好吧，现在我明白了，她完全忘记了。
I forgot about it, and I had actual pasta sauce spilled onto me.
我忘记了，我的意大利面酱洒在了我身上。
And I forgot about it.
我忘了这件事。
You're the person who should have had the strongest visceral memory.
你应该是本能记忆力最强的人。
This vivid, vivid memory, yeah.
这生动、生动的记忆，是的。
Well, yeah, I mean, I think that that speaks to, like, Carter is a crossword puzzle guy, like me.
嗯，是的，我的意思是，我认为这说明卡特是一个填字游戏爱好者，就像我一样。
But I think you both have a sense of like, puzzlemanship, is that a word like?
但我想你们都有一种喜欢的感觉，puzzlemanship，是一个“喜欢”这个词吗？
Puzzlemanship.
解谜术。
You heard it here first, ladies and gentlemen.
女士们先生们，你们首先在这里听到的。
You like things kind of falling into place.
你喜欢事情按部就班。
You like, you got like a good mislead.
你喜欢，你就像一个很好的误导。
You like, what is going on?
你喜欢，这是怎么回事？
Why freeze frame?
为什么要冻结帧？
Let's back up.
让我们备份一下。
Let's show how we got there.
让我们展示一下我们是如何到达那里的。
Yeah.
是的。
We love telling stories like that.
我们喜欢讲这样的故事。
We looked at these seasons, kind of like novels, kind of like you could jump around and really everything should refer to something else.
我们审视了这些季节，有点像小说，有点像你可以跳来跳去，实际上一切都应该指其他东西。
Everything should be there for a reason if it possibly can be.
如果可能的话，一切事物的存在都应该有其原因。
And we really looked at a season as one big organism rather than this series of standalone things, which like we said at the beginning of season two, the network would have probably been happier at the time if we had done standalone episodes that were very digestible, that required little thought.
我们确实将一季视为一个大有机体，而不是这一系列独立的事物，就像我们在第二季开始时所说的那样，如果我们制作非常容易理解的独立剧集，那么网络当时可能会更高兴，这不需要太多思考。
You don't have to have seen them in any particular order.
您不必按任何特定顺序查看它们。
It's just not how we write.
这不是我们写作的方式。
They asked us to do more of that.
他们要求我们做更多这样的事情。
And we kind of said, we'll try knowing that we were not going to try and that we can't.
我们说过，我们会尝试，但我们知道我们不会尝试，也不能尝试。
We could only write it this way.
我们只能这样写。
And I have to say rewatching it feels very vindicating for that decision because it's very fun to watch like this again, right?
我不得不说，重新观看它感觉非常证明了这个决定，因为再次观看这样的视频非常有趣，对吧？
It's very fun to go back and go, this is why everything was here.
来来去去非常有趣，这就是一切都在这里的原因。
But I think the sense of payoff that is tied to the longevity and serialized nature of the show is why people keep coming back to the show, like it's some sort of holy shrine because it rewards your fidelity to it.
但我认为与该剧的长久性和连续性相关的回报感是人们不断回到该剧的原因，就像它是某种圣殿一样，因为它奖励你对它的忠诚。
Like the more you watch it.
越看越喜欢。
It's like, you know, there's- It is, it's little clues.
就像，你知道，有——是的，这是一些线索。
I'm gonna, I know what that clue is gonna, I know what the payoff's gonna be to that clue.
我会，我知道那条线索会是什么，我知道这条线索的回报是什么。
And people like that.
人们喜欢这样。
There's a thing, I think this is from the Bhagavad Gita, forgive me if it's not, but there's some line essentially from like Vedic something where it says, the first taste of ego is sweet, but its fruits are bitter.
有件事，我认为这是来自《薄伽梵歌》，如果不是，请原谅我，但有一些诗句本质上来自吠陀经，它说，自我的初尝是甜的，但它的果实是苦的。
And the first taste of God is bitter, but its fruits are sweet.
神的初尝是苦的，但它的果子却是甜的。
And I feel like what the network was saying was like, give us fruit, sweet, sweet, sweet, give us a thing.
我觉得网络所说的就像是，给我们水果，甜甜甜甜，给我们一个东西。
And then it curdles over time because it's too easy.
然后随着时间的推移它会凝结，因为它太容易了。
But what you guys were saying was like, we're gonna give you something a little more challenging that will ultimately down the line be more rewarding for you.
但你们所说的是，我们会给你们一些更具挑战性的东西，最终会给你们带来更多的回报。
Yeah, it's kind of the ultimate, wait for it.
是的，这是终极版，等等。
Wait for it is kind of the mantra of the series.
等待是该系列的口头禅。
The whole mantra.
整个咒语。
That is the guiding aesthetic of the whole series.
这是整个系列的指导美学。
And the last line of the season.
以及本季的最后一行。
Yeah, which is my favorite, yeah, we'll get there.
是的，这是我最喜欢的，是的，我们会到达那里。
We'll get there in the next one.
我们将在下一篇中到达那里。
But that is one of my, maybe my favorite ending of the season.
但这是我的，也许是我最喜欢的本季结局之一。
We haven't had as the ending of this season, but here we are in a second of the last episode.
本季还没有结束，但我们已经看到了最后一集的第二部分。
I just realized my voice is that I just want to say that I've had this upper respiratory infection for the last couple of days.
我刚刚意识到我的声音是我只想说我最近几天患有上呼吸道感染。
These are our challenges.
这些都是我们面临的挑战。
I'm just, I'm getting through it and it hasn't been fun, but I'm well enough to be here today and I'm thrilled to be here today.
我只是，我正在经历这一切，这并不有趣，但我今天身体很好，很高兴今天能来到这里。
I was really, I was really taken, my wife and I watched the last three episodes all last night.
我真的，我真的很着迷，我和我的妻子昨晚看了最后三集。
And I had this experience, I want to tell you this, it was during the third, it was during something blue.
我有过这样的经历，我想告诉你，那是在第三次，那是在一些蓝色的事情期间。
And it reminded me of, do you know the actor Victor Garber?
这让我想起，你认识演员维克多·加伯吗？
Yeah, a great actor.
是的，一个伟大的演员。
He played the ship's architect in Titanic and he had a long great career.
他在《泰坦尼克号》中扮演了这艘船的建筑师，并拥有一段漫长而伟大的职业生涯。
Another classic architect like Ted.
另一位经典建筑师，如特德。
Yeah, exactly, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
And we did this musical together years ago called She Loves Me and we had a great experience.
几年前我们一起制作了一部音乐剧《她爱我》，我们有一段很棒的经历。
So we had a lot of time to chat.
所以我们有很多时间聊天。
And he was in the original cast of Sweeney Todd, the great Stephen Sondheim musical.
他还是史蒂芬·桑德海姆伟大音乐剧《理发师陶德》的原班人马。
Yeah.
是的。
And he played the young Anjanou.
他扮演年轻的安贾努。
He sings that great song, Joanna.
他唱那首伟大的歌曲，乔安娜。
And he said, they opened the show and he got an offer to do, I think this musical called their playing our song, which is a two-hander musical.
他说，他们开始了演出，他收到了一份邀请，我认为这部音乐剧叫他们演奏我们的歌曲，这是一部两人音乐剧。
He got an offer to go on the road for a lot of money with a big star.
他得到了与一位大明星一起以高价出征的邀请。
And he left Sweeney Todd to go do this.
他离开了理发师陶德去做这件事。
And he thought, this is a good move.
他认为，这是一个很好的举措。
It financially makes sense.
这在经济上是有道理的。
And then he finished the road to where Sweeney Todd was still playing.
然后他走完了通往理发师陶德仍在玩耍的地方的路。
He either got asked to go see it or he just decided to drop in.
他要么被要求去看，要么他决定顺便去看看。
He's sitting in the audience at Sweeney Todd, this musical that he was in the original cast of.
他坐在理发师陶德这部音乐剧的观众席上，他是这部音乐剧的原班演员。
And he's sitting there and he goes, oh my god, I was in this?
他坐在那里然后说，天啊，我也在其中？
Like he was so stunned by what he was watching.
就好像他被眼前的一切惊呆了。
And he had no sense of it being when he was in it.
当他身处其中时，他并没有感觉到它的存在。
When he was in it, how unbelievable it was and how it was breaking form.
当他身临其境时，这是多么令人难以置信，多么令人难以置信。
And it was so extraordinary to him.
这对他来说是如此非凡。
And he couldn't believe he was in it.
他简直不敢相信自己竟然参与其中。
And I had this moment last night watching this where I was like, Oh my God, I was in this.
昨晚我看到这个时刻时，我就想，天哪，我就在其中。
I was in this great, great piece of art.
我置身于这件伟大的艺术作品中。
And I didn't know.
我不知道。
I mean, I knew like, I would tell you like, Oh my God, that's so funny.
我的意思是，我知道，我会告诉你，天哪，这太有趣了。
Or I think this is great.
或者我认为这很棒。
I knew I was on a clever, wonderful show that was gathering steam.
我知道我正在观看一场聪明、精彩的演出，而且正在蓄势待发。
I knew all that.
我知道这一切。
But I didn't have a sense that I was in some I'm sort of like iconic generationally defined.
但我并没有意识到我属于某些代际定义的标志性人物。
That was our hope, but it was so hard for me in the moment to appreciate.
这是我们的希望，但此刻我很难欣赏。
And now all these years later, looking back, I really see like, oh my God, I was a part of something so cool.
现在这么多年过去了，回想起来，我真的发现，天哪，我是这么酷的事情的一部分。
Totally, it's like the best version of the, it's the positive version of the frog in the boiling water.
总而言之，这就像最好的版本，这是沸水里的青蛙的积极版本。
Right, right.
对，对。
It's like our boiling water was, we're on a really good show and the frog's boiling water was it's death, but it's the metaphor falls apart at a certain point.
就像我们的沸水一样，我们正在上演一场非常精彩的表演，而青蛙的沸水则意味着它的死亡，但这个隐喻在某个时刻就崩溃了。
but it's like you don't, you don't quite know what ecosystem you're in as you're making it.
但就像你不知道一样，当你创造它时，你不太知道你所处的生态系统是什么。
You don't, I'm feeling that too.
你不觉得，我也有这种感觉。
I'm watching it going, this is a good show.
我正在看，这是一场好戏。
But these final three of season two, and the one we'll talk about next, something blue, the ending of something blue, which we'll get to, I just remember having this feeling editing that episode, shooting that scene of you and Neil, I'm jumping an episode here, sorry, but having this feeling of this is working.
但是第二季的最后三集，也就是我们接下来要讨论的，一些蓝色的东西，一些蓝色的结局，我们将要谈到的，我只记得编辑那一集，拍摄你和尼尔的场景时有这种感觉，我在这里跳过一集，抱歉，但有这种感觉是有效的。
I had a profound sense of wellbeing with this two-part finale, something borrowed and something blue.
我对这个由两部分组成的结局有一种深深的幸福感，一些借来的东西，一些蓝色的东西。
I just remember feeling like, we did it.
我只记得感觉，我们做到了。
We're on the crab, as they say.
正如他们所说，我们正在吃螃蟹。
Yeah.
是的。
And I wrote you this little day to sing to you in New York City.
今天我写信给你，是为了在纽约为你唱歌。
We'll be right back.
我们马上回来。
Hi, I'm Alex Goldman, host of the Hyper-Fixed Podcast.
大家好，我是 Alex Goldman，Hyper-Fixed 播客的主持人。
Each week, we take listeners' problems and try to solve them for them.
每周，我们都会收集听众的问题并尝试为他们解决。
problems like I'm 30 and I'm scared to drive in New York, or why can't I adjust the volume of my car stereo when I'm in reverse?
比如我已经 30 岁了，我害怕在纽约开车，或者为什么我倒车时无法调节汽车音响的音量？
We also solve non-car related problems.
我们还解决非汽车相关的问题。
If you have a problem, not only will we fix it, we'll expose the hidden systems that caused that problem in the first place.
如果您遇到问题，我们不仅会修复它，还会首先暴露导致该问题的隐藏系统。
That's the Hyper-Fixed Podcast from Radiotopia.
这是来自 Radiotopia 的 Hyper-Fixed 播客。
Find it wherever you find podcasts or at Hyper-FixedPod.com.
无论您在哪里找到播客或在 Hyper-FixedPod.com 上都可以找到它。
And now, back to the show.
现在，回到节目。
I think that television and I would argue music, they're not opening weekend dependent art forms.
我认为电视和我会争论音乐，他们并没有开放周末依赖的艺术形式。
No, it's the long tail.
不，是长尾巴。
It's the long.
就是长的那个
It's the initial sales of an album.
这是专辑的首次销售。
Do not speak to how long or how impactful that album will be culturally.
不要谈论该专辑将持续多久或在文化上有多大影响力。
And it's the same thing with TV, especially something we gave people a treasure trove of, I'm actually startled when we, we've covered so much, the first two seasons have so much in them and so many, my memory is, are very strong of, even though I forget large patches.
电视也是如此，尤其是我们给人们提供了一个宝库的东西，当我们覆盖了这么多内容时，我真的很惊讶，前两季有这么多内容，而且我的记忆力很强，尽管我忘记了大块内容。
I can't believe we have seven more seasons to go.
我不敢相信我们还有七个赛季要踢。
It's actually, it's how much of this would be.
事实上，这就是多少。
I'm curious to see how he's strung it out for that long.
我很好奇他是如何坚持这么久的。
I hope some of them are good.
我希望其中一些是好的。
I was looking at the bar and I was just like, oh my God, we spent so much time now in that bar in that booth.
我看着酒吧，心想，天哪，我们在那个酒吧的那个摊位上花了很多时间。
It's basically a decade or a life.
基本上是十年或一生。
If you round up just a little.
如果你稍微四舍五入的话。
Yeah, it's crazy.
是的，这太疯狂了。
But I had such a feeling of like, I remembered the feeling of excitement and spark of the of this episode.
但我有一种感觉，我记得这一集的兴奋和火花。
And the one who follows like, this is a great episode.
关注的人会说，这是很棒的一集。
Greg Mayland's did a great job writing this episode.
格雷格·梅兰（Greg Mayland）在编写这一集时做得非常出色。
Marshall Millies vows outside when they when the wedding is going so terribly and they relocate outside into one of our one of like four location shoots in the entire history of home at your mother.
当婚礼进行得如此糟糕时，马歇尔·米利斯在外面发誓，他们搬到了我们在你母亲的整个家庭历史上的四个拍摄地点之一的外面。
And we're at the park right across the street.
我们就在街对面的公园里。
It was our big field trip.
这是我们的大型实地考察。
We had the first big field trip.
我们进行了第一次大型实地考察。
We drove across Pico Boulevard from the Fox lot to a park that is literally right there Rancho Park, right?
我们从福克斯停车场开车穿过皮科大道，来到了一个公园，那确实就在兰乔公园，对吗？
That's what it's called.
这就是它的名字。
It's like Chevy Chevy Hills Rancho Park.
这就像雪佛兰雪佛兰山牧场公园。
And that is that was our huge ambitious location.
这就是我们雄心勃勃的巨大地点。
We kept talking about like one day we're going to shoot in New York City and never happened.
我们一直在谈论有一天我们要在纽约拍摄，但从未发生过。
But we did get to Rancho Park.
但我们确实到达了兰乔公园。
We got to Rancho Park and then in like season seven or eight, we got to universe the universal lot to shoot Subway words.
我们到了兰乔公园，然后在第七季或第八季中，我们到了环球影城来拍摄《地铁》中的文字。
And that was that was the farthest away we ever got.
那是我们曾经到达过的最远的距离。
We never got outside of Los Angeles.
我们从未离开过洛杉矶。
But boy, that that park was great.
但是天哪，那个公园很棒。
And that yeah, I was texting with Pam earlier and she said, I said, do you remember shooting that?
是的，我早些时候给帕姆发短信，她说，我说，你还记得拍摄那个吗？
Was that right across the street in that park right by the Fox on?
是在街对面的那个公园里，就在狐狸旁边吗？
She said, yes, I remember, I just remember it was like having class outside.
她说，是的，我记得，我只记得就像在外面上课一样。
That's exactly what it felt like.
这正是我的感觉。
We were all having such a good time.
我们都玩得很开心。
And she said to try to send some photos.
她说尝试发送一些照片。
I don't like if she doesn't put some people, you know how you could to kind of either get a lift down in New York Street or walk it.
我不喜欢如果她不安排一些人，你知道你怎么可能在纽约街搭便车或步行。
It's right there.
它就在那里。
I always like walking.
我一向喜欢散步。
It is a literal stone's throw away, but it's a beautiful park.
虽然距离酒店只有一箭之遥，但它是一个美丽的公园。
It really did the trick.
它确实起到了作用。
It felt east coast somehow.
不知怎的，感觉像是东海岸。
It felt very green.
感觉很绿色。
It felt it did not feel like Southern California.
感觉不像南加州。
It looked great.
看起来很棒。
And that whole sequence is so sweet.
整个过程非常甜蜜。
They're vows.
他们是誓言。
And the fact that they really get married only with this group and almost feels like the whole group is getting married.
事实上，他们真的只与这个群体结婚，几乎感觉整个群体都在结婚。
At the end of season two, they're all just admitting that they're the most important people to each other who cares about all that family and all the chaos within that wedding venue, let's admit, let's agree what's important here and it's us.
在第二季结束时，他们都承认他们是彼此最重要的人，关心整个家庭和婚礼场地内的所有混乱，让我们承认，让我们同意这里最重要的是我们。
And I think that's great.
我认为这很棒。
It also, I think contained within it is one of the larger lessons of how I met your mother's like, you can do all the planning in the world that you want.
我认为其中包含的也是我如何认识你母亲的更大的教训之一，就像你可以在世界上做你想做的所有计划。
And sometimes what's right in front of you is the thing that needs to happen.
有时，摆在你面前的事情正是需要发生的。
That's your life, your life is happening there.
那就是你的生活，你的生活就在那里发生。
You think it's happening somewhere else, but it's actually happening there.
你认为它发生在其他地方，但它实际上发生在那里。
And if you pay attention, that's where the magic is too.
如果你留心的话，你会发现这也正是神奇之处。
And that is what the end of that episode feels like to me.
这就是那集的结尾给我的感觉。
Mail-ins wrote a great set of vows that they're improvised vows.
邮寄的誓言写了一套很棒的誓言，它们是即兴的誓言。
I feel like that was mostly Greg.
我觉得那主要是格雷格。
I did just have the memory of the script coming in.
我确实只记得剧本进来了。
It was so sweet and nice.
真是太甜蜜太美好了。
We probably tweaked it a little, but it was really well done.
我们可能稍微调整了一下，但做得确实很好。
Here's my one regret, ready?
这是我的一个遗憾，准备好了吗？
I like to share regrets.
我喜欢分享遗憾。
I like to admit when I think we kind of dropped a ball.
当我认为我们有点失败时，我愿意承认。
We were talking about how much we hold on to setups and payoffs.
我们正在谈论我们对设置和回报的坚持程度。
I think we dropped a setup a little bit.
我认为我们稍微放弃了一些设置。
Not that it would have been great.
并不是说那会很棒。
And maybe you guys talk me out of feeling bad about this one, but earlier in the season, we made a bit of hay about the fact that Lily was needed to face Marshall's family's ire for canceling the wedding months and months earlier when she broke up with Marshall and delaying the wedding and then we're going to get married in Atlantic City.
也许你们劝我不要对这件事感到难过，但在本季早些时候，我们对这样一个事实做了一些干草：莉莉需要面对马歇尔家人的愤怒，因为她在几个月前与马歇尔分手并推迟了婚礼，然后我们将在大西洋城结婚。
And then it was like, no, we got to go face the music.
然后就好像，不，我们必须面对现实。
We got to go be there.
我们必须去那里。
And Lily has to stand up in front of Marshall's family and we need to see her do that right of passage.
莉莉必须站在马歇尔的家人面前，我们需要看到她做到这一点。
And then we just didn't fucking show it at all in this episode.
然后我们在这一集里根本就没有表现出来。
We had a different idea.
我们有不同的想法。
different.
不同的。
I love what we did because what we did got them to these vows.
我喜欢我们所做的事情，因为我们所做的事情让他们达成了这些誓言。
But I feel like there should have been one beat where it was like Marshall's family.
但我觉得应该有一个像马歇尔一家那样的节奏。
We still haven't forgiven you for breaking up.
我们还没有原谅你的分手。
Is Marshall's family even in this episode?
马歇尔的家人也在这一集中吗？
They're not.
他们不是。
And I think it was probably, yes.
我认为可能是的。
Actually, Renee.sharbon09 does ask, why weren't Marshall's family members there?
事实上，Renee.sharbon09 确实问过，为什么马歇尔的家人不在场？
It was a very big episode.
这是一个非常大的插曲。
Again, our first location shoot, one block from the Fox Lab.
这又是我们的第一次外景拍摄，距福克斯实验室一个街区。
But believe it or not, it still costs a lot of money to relocate to one block from the Fox Latin to.
但不管你信不信，搬到距福克斯拉丁区一个街区仍然要花很多钱。
And I think the episode right cost a bunch of money.
我认为这一集花了很多钱。
We weren't a huge hit yet.
我们还没有大受欢迎。
And my suspicion is it was like, well, we could spend a whole bunch of money to hire all those extra Eric's and folks for like one scene.
我怀疑这就像，好吧，我们可以花一大笔钱来雇佣所有额外的埃里克和其他人来完成一个场景。
But let's not do that because it's too much money.
但我们不要这样做，因为钱太多了。
That's the if we thought about it at all, we may have taught ourselves out of it in that way.
如果我们认真思考一下，我们可能已经以这种方式教会了自己摆脱它。
Retrospectively, I sort of wish we had done that just so it could have felt like we threaded that one little needle.
回想起来，我有点希望我们这样做只是为了感觉就像我们穿了一根小针一样。
I don't think it's important.
我认为这并不重要。
I don't think it would have changed the episode substantively.
我不认为这会对剧情有实质性的改变。
But that was, I I'm admitting that every now and again, let everybody watch these things, like, ah, we could have been that.
但那是，我承认，时不时地，让每个人都观看这些事情，就像，啊，我们本来可以那样。
Well, sometimes the 22 minutes is absolutely clarifying, and it challenges you to be at your most efficient, most streamlined kind of thinking.
好吧，有时 22 分钟绝对能让你理清思路，它会挑战你以最高效、最精简的方式思考。
And other times you're like, yeah, it's 22 minutes.
有时你会想，是的，只有 22 分钟。
I wish we had five extra minutes, and we just could have done a little sequence about that.
我希望我们还有五分钟的时间，我们可以就此做一些序列。
But then it would have been the lovely ending of that episode would have been even more squashed, and we would have had to cut other stuff that I like.
但那样的话，那一集的可爱结局就会被更加压扁，我们就不得不剪掉我喜欢的其他东西。
And I love scooter in this episode, the Neil's actual real life partner, David Burka, not really a husband now.
我喜欢这一集中的滑板车，尼尔的现实生活伴侣大卫·布尔卡，现在并不是真正的丈夫。
And Joe Manganella was so funny in this one.
乔·曼加内拉在这部电影中非常有趣。
And just like, it's great.
就像，这太棒了。
It's a three ring circus of madness.
这是一个三环的疯狂马戏团。
And I love the theme that emerges from it, but I missed that one thing.
我喜欢其中出现的主题，但我错过了这一件事。
I will also say I'm not much to Jordana's chagrin.
我还要说我并没有让乔丹娜懊恼。
I'm not, as she says, I don't have a lot of TV stamina.
我并不像她说的那样，没有太多看电视的耐力。
Like she likes to watch a bunch of episodes.
就像她喜欢看一堆剧集一样。
And we watched three last night, And I was initially like, oh my God, three, it's a lot, that's a lot, it's a big mountain to climb up.
我们昨晚看了三部，我一开始就想，天啊，三部，太多了，太多了，这是一座需要爬的大山。
They were over before I knew, like, this show goes down smooth.
在我意识到之前他们就结束了，就像这个节目进展顺利一样。
You can burn through a bunch of episodes in a very quick, satisfying way.
您可以以非常快速、令人满意的方式烧完一堆剧集。
They go down really easily.
他们真的很容易倒下。
They go by really, really fast.
他们走得非常非常快。
Yeah, I think I watched two or three of these last few with Rebecca and I was like, I was sad they were over.
是的，我想我和丽贝卡一起看了最后几部中的两三部，我当时想，我很伤心他们结束了。
They went by really, really fast.
他们走得非常非常快。
And then in this one, I was thinking, this one did leave me wanting more.
然后在这一篇中，我在想，这确实让我想要更多。
I wanted that one beat more that we didn't do.
我想要多一拍，但我们没有做到。
but you're right, sometimes that challenge, painting yourself into that small corner, 22 minutes, I'd say more often than not, that was a good thing.
但你是对的，有时这种挑战，让自己陷入那个小角落，22 分钟，我经常说，这是一件好事。
Even though every now and again, you kick yourself, you go, I wish we could have done this.
即使时不时地，你踢自己，你走，我希望我们能做到这一点。
But usually I think that it necessities the mother that keeps you leaning out any fat from it.
但通常我认为母亲需要让你从中排出任何脂肪。
You're like, unless it's hilarious, it has to go.
你会想，除非它很搞笑，否则它就必须消失。
Or unless it's plot, you know, necessary.
或者除非这是情节，你知道，必要的。
And often we would do both, when it can be hilarious and advancing the plot at the same time, that's the dream.
通常我们会同时做这两件事，当它可以很搞笑的同时推进情节时，这就是梦想。
And it forces you to do that.
它迫使你这样做。
You know, I also though, this episode, like we talked about like everything in, especially Lily's perfect idea of a wedding goes wrong.
你知道，我也一样，这一集，就像我们谈论的一切一样，尤其是莉莉关于婚礼的完美想法出了问题。
Like that must have been fun in a writer's room.
在作家的房间里一定很有趣。
Like, okay, perfect wedding, everything goes wrong.
就像，好吧，完美的婚礼，一切都出了问题。
Go, right?
走吧，对吗？
Like isn't that kind of, it's a great assignment for a writer's room.
不是那样的，这对于作家的房间来说是一项很棒的任务。
All of your hopes and expectations.
你所有的希望和期望。
What's the checklist of everything you want to happen and everything you don't want to happen?
你想要发生的一切和你不希望发生的一切的清单是什么？
And you fuck up all the things that are on the list A and you do all the things on list B.
你把A清单上的所有事情都搞砸了，然后又做了B清单上的所有事情。
Scooter showing up the super the super pregnant heart player.
滑板车现身超级超级孕心选手。
She was very funny.
她很有趣。
That was a good guest performance.
这是一场很好的客串表演。
Yeah, very Every every like guest star is guest star on the show was really good like David Berkos really funny Oh my god, when he won't make I can't wait.
是的，非常每个像客串明星都是节目中的客串明星，就像大卫·伯科斯（David Berkos）一样非常好，非常有趣哦天哪，当他不会让我等不及的时候。
He won't make eye contact is one of the biggest laughs in the episode It really is he would say if you could look me in the eye and tell me you want to marry Marshall Then he it is such a stupid joke and he leaned into it with such exquisite earnestness But also David, I know he went to University of Michigan from musical theater, which is a great, like one of the best in the country.
他不会进行目光接触是这一集里最大的笑点之一，他真的会说，如果你能看着我的眼睛，告诉我你想嫁给马歇尔，那么他这是一个愚蠢的笑话，他以如此精致的认真态度来对待它，还有大卫，我知道他从音乐剧学院毕业，这是一个伟大的大学，就像全国最好的大学之一。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Sometimes when an actor has, like Roger Bart, member, like when he was on season nine, like certain actors who have either a dance background or a musical theater background, sometimes they can lean into physicality.
有时，当一个演员像罗杰·巴特那样，像他在第九季时那样，像某些具有舞蹈背景或音乐剧背景的演员一样，有时他们可以倾向于身体。
Yeah, you see David's dancing, the dancers, the dance movement.
是的，你看到大卫的舞蹈、舞者、舞蹈动作。
He's like a movement.
他就像一场运动。
It was so funny and it was so like committed to it.
这太有趣了，而且就像是致力于它一样。
It's like a cartoon.
就像动画片一样。
Yeah.
是的。
Scooter is an animated character.
斯库特是一个动画角色。
Like Scooter is absolutely from the world of animation.
像Scooter一样绝对是来自动画世界。
He wandered out of the Simpsons or something.
他走出了辛普森一家之类的地方。
He came from somewhere else.
他来自其他地方。
He just goes to or something.
他只是去什么地方。
Staggard into the show.
踉踉跄跄地进入演出。
David is having a lot of fun with that.
大卫对此很感兴趣。
I also love, I mean, just the scene with him and Neil, if you know, you know, is so funny, just because they're so funny.
我也喜欢，我的意思是，他和尼尔的场景，如果你知道，你知道，非常有趣，只是因为他们非常有趣。
They're such strangers to each other.
他们彼此是如此陌生。
Yeah, and I love how Brad on the show really likes Scooter until he realizes he's Scooter.
是的，我喜欢剧中布拉德非常喜欢斯库特，直到他意识到自己是斯库特。
You know, once he knows his scooter, he's like instantly wants to go kill him and tackle him.
你知道，一旦他了解了他的摩托车，他就会立刻想要杀了他并抓住他。
And it's funny how Brad is so open to being like a hired goon, like he's like, tell me who to tackle.
有趣的是，布拉德如此开放地像一个雇佣的打手一样，就像他一样，告诉我该对付谁。
He really seems like he's being paid.
看来他确实是得到了报酬。
He seems like he's Frank Sinatra's body garb.
他看起来就像是弗兰克·辛纳屈 (Frank Sinatra) 的紧身衣。
I love that, you know, Brad, especially in this season, became like, he's just in the constellation of kind of a peripheral characters that you can always depend on to be funny Instantly has presence like he can come in and matter by being on there for three seconds.
我喜欢这一点，你知道，布拉德，尤其是在这一季，变得像，他只是一种边缘角色，你总是可以依靠他来搞笑，立即就有存在感，就像他可以在场三秒钟就进来并发挥作用。
And it's yeah, it's great Yeah, there's a lot of like classic like door slamming and popping into rooms and in and out of rooms really quickly Yeah, it's shot out of a cannon until then it slows it earns that slower ending outside Like I think that was that's gone.
是的，这太棒了是的，有很多类似的经典，比如关门、突然进入房间、快速进出房间是的，它是从大炮中射出的，直到它放慢速度，它才会在外面得到较慢的结局，就像我认为那已经过去了。
We have this location shoot.
我们有这个外景拍摄。
We have a fucking jib like a crane We are going to like milk the beauty of the fact that we're in this beautiful park having this beautiful scene and And I love yet again, that softer side of Barney comes out.
我们有一个像起重机一样的吊臂我们会喜欢牛奶这个事实的美丽，我们在这个美丽的公园里有这个美丽的场景，我再次喜欢巴尼温柔的一面。
Barney is the first one crying at the wedding.
巴尼是婚礼上第一个哭泣的人。
Yeah, okay.
是啊，好吧。
So the first half of this are, it's really like a Lily Barney Robin sing in the bride's suite.
所以前半部分真的就像莉莉·巴尼·罗宾在新娘套房里唱的那样。
I mean, it's so great how Barney discovers this superpower.
我的意思是，巴尼发现这种超能力真是太棒了。
It's for the bride.
是给新娘的。
Yeah, that was very fun.
是的，那非常有趣。
And there is, you know, having been married two years ago, like there is something about the power of the bride on a wedding day is like no other thing.
你知道，两年前结婚，新娘在婚礼当天的力量是独一无二的。
The groom has nothing of fraction of it.
新郎什么也没有。
The groom barely rates compared to the power of the bride.
与新娘的权力相比，新郎几乎没有什么价值。
And that's how it should be for the bride is that those are the three magic words.
对于新娘来说，这就是三个神奇的词。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And it's so funny how he tests that and uses that.
他如何测试并使用它真是太有趣了。
He's such an asshole to the bartender at first.
起初他对调酒师来说真是个混蛋。
You know, he really, I was on, I was team bartender and that's him, I was like, stop being such a douche.
你知道，他真的，我在场，我是团队调酒师，那就是他，我当时想，别再这么混蛋了。
He was dushing out super hard at the bar tender.
他在调酒师面前非常卖力。
Yeah, but Barney, Barney finding that new toy.
是的，但是巴尼，巴尼找到了那个新玩具。
It's basically like a little kid finds a dangerous new toy.
这基本上就像一个小孩发现了一个危险的新玩具。
Like a toy he's not supposed to have, that he could break, that's expensive.
就像一个他不应该拥有的玩具，他可能会打破，这很昂贵。
And he just starts going bananas with it.
他就开始发疯了。
That's that whole story.
这就是整个故事。
At the beginning of the episode when she says, oh, the less the less nurse canceled her ever.
在剧集开始时，她说，哦，护士取消她的次数越少。
And Robin's like, less nurse is more, nurse.
和罗宾一样，少护士就是多护士。
And she tries to explain it to Ted.
她试图向特德解释这一点。
And what is he said?
他说了什么？
He says, yeah, this is one of those times, sweetie.
他说，是的，这就是这样的时刻之一，亲爱的。
That whole run really made me laugh.
整个跑步过程真的让我笑了。
That's a great run.
这是一次很棒的跑步。
Yeah.
是的。
And I love the line, did he look like a guy who tried to be an umpire and failed?
我喜欢这句话，他看起来像一个试图成为裁判但失败的人吗？
He did.
他做到了。
Lily, how he had a reaction to scooter that made us laugh so hard.
莉莉，他对滑板车的反应让我们笑得很厉害。
I don't remember what it was, but she just had a face that was just so funny.
我不记得那是什么，但她的脸实在是太有趣了。
But look me in the eye, like I said, maybe for me the biggest laugh of the episode.
但就像我说的，看着我的眼睛，也许对我来说这是这一集最大的笑点。
It was so funny.
太有趣了。
And also, it's a great thing.
而且，这是一件很棒的事情。
The other great thing about Scooter coming in is Scooter thinks he's the main character in that episode.
斯库特加入的另一个伟大的事情是斯库特认为他是该集的主角。
Like I always love that feeling of like, this, he's in his movie.
就像我一直喜欢那种感觉，他在他的电影里。
He's in the- He's in the- He's in the Graduate.
他在——他在——他在研究生院。
He's in the Graduate.
他是研究生。
He's in the Climactic scene of the movie in his mind.
他的脑海里正处于电影的高潮场景中。
And Lily's just like, no, no, no, just get out of here.
莉莉就说，不，不，不，离开这里吧。
No, that's not where we're gonna have it.
不，那不是我们要的地方。
It's funny and heartbreaking.
这很有趣又令人心碎。
Yeah.
是的。
Of course, Scooter.
当然是滑板车。
I love when Lily says, oh, grow up, Robin, of course I want a perfect wedding.
我喜欢莉莉说，哦，长大了，罗宾，我当然想要一个完美的婚礼。
Yeah, yeah, I know.
是的，是的，我知道。
It goes a long time that that we're like, I don't care.
很长一段时间我们都觉得，我不在乎。
It's all good.
一切都很好。
I've got Marshall and nothing else matters.
我有马歇尔，其他都不重要。
And it's like, no, I'm getting it.
就像，不，我明白了。
It's fucking matters.
这他妈的很重要。
You want it?
你想要吗？
But then we swing over to Marshall and the disastrous moment.
但接下来我们转向马歇尔和灾难性的时刻。
How have we waited this long to get to this?
我们怎么等了这么久才到这一步？
Josh, I feel like you said to me, this is the hardest you've ever laughed or the most you've almost lost it.
乔什，我感觉你对我说，这是你笑过的最难笑的一次，或者是你几乎失去笑容的一次。
This is the most I've had to suppress a laugh.
这是我最忍住笑的一次。
The main question that we get from the internet on this one is of Scotty Ross, we could read his, he says, we all probably want to know, was Jason's hair really shaved down the middle or was that Hollywood magic?
我们从互联网上得到的关于这个问题的主要问题是斯科蒂·罗斯（Scotty Ross），我们可以阅读他的文章，他说，我们可能都想知道，杰森的头发真的是从中间剃掉的，还是好莱坞的魔法？
I've paused and zoomed in on that moment and I just don't see a skullcap.
我停下来放大那一刻，但我只是没有看到一顶无边便帽。
And of course, you have the big question is, Josh, were you really laughing?
当然，你有一个大问题是，乔什，你真的在​​笑吗？
All right, we'll answer both of those questions.
好吧，我们将回答这两个问题。
Okay.
好的。
One thing I didn't want to say, so we get the scripts that you sent out, right?
有件事我不想说，所以我们得到了你发出的脚本，对吗？
But also, remember, the costume department gets the script, the hair department gets the script, makeup, props, all the, you know, set dressing, because they have to read the script through their lens of like, what do we need to do?
但还要记住，服装部门得到剧本，发型部门得到剧本、化妆、道具，所有的，你知道的，布景，因为他们必须通过他们的镜头来阅读剧本，我们需要做什么？
Now the hair department on this got a real assignment, right?
现在头发部门接到了真正的任务，对吧？
So they need, they need to give martial frosted tips and they need an effect where he takes a razor and does a reverse mohawk like a landing strip in the center of his head on television like not like no, like they have to figure that out, right?
所以他们需要，他们需要给出军事磨砂技巧，他们需要一种效果，即他拿着剃须刀，在电视上的头中央做一个反向莫霍克，就像一个着陆带，而不是不，就像他们必须弄清楚这一点，对吗？
It's gonna look like it really happened.
看起来就像真的发生过一样。
It's not that you don't see the result of it.
并不是说你看不到它的结果。
You see it happening.
你看到它发生了。
So my memory and we can call, you know, Tina or whoever was doing, but was Tina on this second season?
所以我的记忆，我们可以打电话给蒂娜或任何正在做的人，但是蒂娜参加了第二季吗？
I think she was.
我想她是。
Yes, because we saw her.
是的，因为我们看到了她。
Oh, we saw her.
哦，我们看到她了。
Yeah.
是的。
So I think what they did was they bald-capped Jason, right?
所以我认为他们所做的就是秃头杰森，对吗？
They bald, that's what they did.
他们秃头，这就是他们所做的。
They bald-capped Jason, and it looked fucking great.
他们给杰森剃了光头，看起来棒极了。
Yeah, they bald-capped Jason with like some stubble, and then they put on a frosted tip wig, right?
是的，他们给杰森剃了光头，留了一些胡茬，然后戴上了磨砂假发，对吧？
Yeah, exactly.
是的，完全正确。
So his real hair is bound down under some really tight under something that looks like a pale scalp.
所以他的真发被绑得很紧，看起来像是苍白的头皮。
But I remember we obviously could not rehearse this other than kind of miming through it.
但我记得我们显然无法排练，只能通过模仿来完成。
Yeah, they must have made at least two, if they've fucked up, if they must've had at least two, maybe three of that, but right, you only had to do it once, it worked so well.
是的，如果他们搞砸了，他们一定至少做了两个，如果他们一定做了至少两个，也许三个，但是对的，你只需要做一次，效果很好。
Yeah, it looked so good, we did it once.
是的，它看起来很好，我们做过一次。
God, I wonder if the only had one, but I bet they made it.
天哪，我想知道是否是唯一的一个拥有这个，但我敢打赌他们做到了。
I'm pretty sure we did it once, because it was like, and the other thing that was so hard for me was, because I knew he nailed a fact.
我很确定我们曾经做过一次，因为它就像，而另一件事对我来说是如此困难，因为我知道他确定了一个事实。
So I felt like if I am laughing, I don't wanna ruin that take, because that's a huge reset, right?
所以我觉得如果我笑了，我不想破坏这个镜头，因为这是一个巨大的重置，对吧？
Right, yeah.
对，是的。
That would take, that would take an hour to reset.
这需要一个小时才能重置。
And also you just watched a guy hit a half court basketball shot.
而且你刚刚看到一个人打了半场篮球。
Exactly.
确切地。
Like he, that could have fucked up so many ways.
像他一样，这可能会在很多方面搞砸。
And we would have like, stuff, stuff, stuff, stuff, stuff, stuff.
我们会有类似的东西，东西，东西，东西，东西，东西。
You know, like, trying to preserve it if we could, but he nailed it and it was, it was, after it was magical, how well he did that.
你知道，如果可以的话，我们会尽力保护它，但他成功了，在神奇之后，他做得多么好。
What made me laugh, and I don't remember if he did this in rehearsals, but the way, you know how Jason would kind of do like Fazibare?
是什么让我笑了，我不记得他是否在排练中这样做了，但是你知道杰森会如何像法兹巴尔那样做吗？
Yeah.
是的。
Like that was kind of a bit of it.
就像那样。
His whole life was him doing Fazibare.
他的一生都在做法兹巴尔。
Yeah, he was like, he was a Fosy Bear aficionado.
是的，他就像，他是福西熊的粉丝。
He loves Fosy.
他爱福西。
And he kind of, he grabbed it, I remember he grabbed it and he went, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, ah, and just this insane thing, and when he did it, I was so shocked, one that it worked, to how ridiculous it was and how hilarious it was.
他抓住了它，我记得他抓住了它，然后就走了，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，啊，这太疯狂了当他做到这一点时，我感到非常震惊，它起作用了，它是多么荒谬，多么搞笑。
And I was like, I had this, it was, I was not acting in that moment.
我当时想，我有这个，那一刻我没有表演。
When I was doing what's going, oh my God, because also there's something unbelievably hilarious and upsetting, like there's eight different emotions going on.
当我在做正在发生的事情时，天哪，因为还有一些令人难以置信的搞笑和令人不安的事情，就像有八种不同的情绪在发生。
It is, it's psychotic.
是的，这是精神病。
He looks so fucking crazy.
他看起来真他妈的疯狂。
Dude, the look at his face is so crazy.
兄弟，看他的表情真是太疯狂了。
And he turns around like Jack Nicholson in the shining.
他转身就像《闪灵》中的杰克·尼科尔森一样。
Like he looks absolutely unhinged when he turns around.
当他转身时，他看起来完全精神错乱。
Unhinged, unhinged is the word.
精神错乱，就是这个词。
Or this was his solution to the cool guy test.
或者这就是他对酷人测试的解决方案。
How was, what was his plan?
怎么样，他的计划是什么？
How was that going to dig him out of that hole?
怎么才能把他从坑里挖出来呢？
So I was watching it with my wife Rebecca and I rewound and watched it again two more times.
所以我和我的妻子丽贝卡一起看这部电影，然后我倒带又看了两遍。
I think I watched it three times total because of you.
我想我是因为你才看了三遍的。
Like, your laugh was so genuine and funny.
就像，你的笑声是如此真诚和有趣。
You're playing six things on your face, including I, Josh Radner, don't want to ruin this take.
你在脸上玩了六件事，包括我，乔什·拉德纳，不想毁掉这个镜头。
It's also there, but there's like other layers to it too, and it's so genuinely, you're horrified, but you know it's the funniest thing ever too, like Ted.
它也在那里，但也有其他层面的东西，而且它是如此真实，你会感到震惊，但你知道这也是有史以来最有趣的事情，就像特德一样。
I mean, Ted knows it's the funniest thing ever.
我的意思是，特德知道这是有史以来最有趣的事情。
Josh does also, but everything about the reaction shot is just pure joy to me.
乔什也这么做了，但反应镜头的一切对我来说都是纯粹的快乐。
But part of the joy and the challenge of it was we had never actually done it.
但其中的乐趣和挑战之一是我们从未真正做到过。
It was like a stunt.
这就像一个特技。
We did one time, we did it one time.
我们做了一次，我们做了一次。
You look like Christmas morning.
你看起来就像圣诞节的早晨。
You look like a kid on Christmas morning.
圣诞节早上你看起来就像个孩子。
It was a miracle, it was a miracle.
这是一个奇迹，这是一个奇迹。
Yes, it was a miracle.
是的，这是一个奇迹。
It should not have gone that well.
事情本来不应该那么顺利。
It does not usually work out like that when you have.
当你有的时候，通常不会有这样的结果。
I also, I remember in, I think it was even the table read, but when the hairdresser says to him, you want some cool guy tips.
我也记得，我想这甚至是桌子上写的，但是当理发师对他说，你想要一些很酷的小技巧。
And he says, I don't know if I need any tips on that.
他说，我不知道是否需要任何建议。
I'm pretty cool, but I guess that really made me laugh.
我很酷，但我想这真的让我笑了。
How about the good, not even the good Backstreet Boys.
好的怎么样，甚至连好的后街男孩也不行。
The good Backstreet Boys.
优秀的后街男孩。
Yeah.
是的。
And this old man, he musted me, fell in love with you, knew who you were sitting.
这位老人，他必须我，爱上了你，知道你坐在谁的身边。
And now commercials.
现在是广告。
End of commercials, back to show.
广告结束，回到节目。
But also then Ted and Barney's attempts to help him through his crisis.
但随后泰德和巴尼也试图帮助他度过危机。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
And Neil's take behind in the deep background behind Over Jason's shoulder when he's trying to act like it's good.
当杰森试图表现得很好时，尼尔在杰森背后的深处采取了行动。
No, the two pay is good.
不，两人的报酬都不错。
The two pay is going to work.
两个工资就可以工作了。
Yeah, sorry, I'm jumping to the toupee with you.
是的，抱歉，我要和你一起戴假发。
Oh my God, a reaction, a reaction shot masterclass in this whole episode.
天哪，反应，整个剧集中的反应镜头大师班。
The toupee scene with the uncle is really funny.
和叔叔的假发场景真的很有趣。
That was really funny.
那真的很有趣。
And he played it great.
他打得很棒。
I mean, that guy just like, where would you find him?
我的意思是，那个家伙就像，你会在哪里找到他？
That would work.
那行得通。
It was also long.
时间也很长。
It was long.
时间很长。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
See, that's really short scenes.
看，这真是短场景。
You gave yourself the time with that guy.
你给了自己和那个人在一起的时间。
And now to go back on my earlier statement, if we had a whole bunch of Erickson's running around to tend to, I don't know if you get the wig, right?
现在回到我之前的声明，如果我们有一大堆埃里克森的人跑来跑去，我不知道你是否得到了假发，对吧？
Something's got to give in 22 minutes.
22 分钟之内就必须有所放弃。
Are you like that?
你是这样的吗？
These are the trade offs.
这些是权衡。
Well, it has to be long enough and complicated enough for Barney's snatching of the thing to pay off.
好吧，它必须足够长、足够复杂，巴尼抢到的东西才能得到回报。
Right.
正确的。
To pay off.
为了还清。
On every level.
在各个层面上。
To pay off.
为了还清。
We should just end the recording right here.
我们应该就在这里结束录音。
I'm like, this is the apex of this episode.
我想，这是这一集的高潮。
To pay off.
为了还清。
That is unbelievable, actually.
事实上，这令人难以置信。
It's unbelievable.
真是难以置信。
This is magic as seagull shaving the perfect landing strip.
这就像海鸥刮过完美的着陆跑道一样神奇。
Yeah, we got it to pay off, I think is the name of this.
是的，我们得到了回报，我想这就是这个名字。
Okay, that's we just came up with it again.
好吧，那是我们刚刚又想出来的。
That will be when you click on the episode, that's what it will be called.
当你点击该剧集时，它就会被命名为这个名字。
Fuck, that was that it really was when he turns around and he briefly is like weirdly calm about it for one second.
操，那确实是当他转身的时候，他短暂地异常平静了一秒钟。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
He's like, I think it's with the solution.
他说，我认为这就是解决方案。
I solved it.
我解决了。
As if he solved his whole life, like I can finally see what life or the point of life is.
仿佛他解决了他的一生，就像我终于能明白什么是生命，生命的意义是什么。
He had like this weird clarity to him.
他有一种奇怪的清晰度。
It's like, no, it really, it did look like someone who had broken with reality in like a pretty strong way.
就好像，不，真的，它看起来确实像是一个以相当强烈的方式与现实决裂的人。
Yeah.
是的。
And out of body experiences being had there, and it's, oh my God, uh, the two pays amazing.
在那里有灵魂出窍的体验，天哪，呃，两者的回报惊人。
I remember feeling like Jason had some, I mean, we can ask him about this, but I remembered thinking, like, he loves this, like, he loved getting to do this, like this insane.
我记得感觉杰森有一些，我的意思是，我们可以问他这件事，但我记得我想，就像，他喜欢这个，就像，他喜欢这样做，就像这样疯狂。
It's like the home run hitting contest in baseball, just watching people just put him put him over and over again into deep left center.
这就像棒球中的本垒打比赛，只是看着人们把他一次又一次地推到左中深处。
Like that's that was legal on that whole this whole episode.
就这样，整个事件都是合法的。
He's hilarious.
他很搞笑。
I really do.
我真的这么做。
I know it was 19 years ago, which is astonishing to think about, but I have such a strong memory of watching Jason go.
我知道那是 19 年前的事了，想想就令人惊讶，但看着杰森离去的情景我记忆犹新。
You talk about it.
你说说吧。
I want to say like not on the pod like between us, you've talked about that moment so many times and he's, I remember you just talking about the look in Jason's like the look in his eyes, to look in his face when he turned to you, that it was terrifying and hilarious at the same time because Seagull's six foot four.
我想说的是，就像不是在我们之间的吊舱上，你已经多次谈论过那一刻，而他，我记得你刚刚谈到杰森的表情，就像他的眼神，当他转向你时看着他的脸，这既可怕又搞笑，因为海鸥有六英尺四英寸高。
And now he's turning around and he looks like, like Doc Brown on meth.
现在他转过身来，看起来就像吸毒的布朗医生一样。
He looks like Colonel Kurtz in apocalypse now.
他现在看起来就像是末世中的库尔茨上校。
It's like he really, he's been in the jungle way too long.
就好像他真的一样，他在丛林里呆得太久了。
So long, he's gone.
这么久了，他已经走了。
Yeah, his brain is gone, he's detached from reality.
是的，他的大脑已经消失了，他脱离了现实。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, it's, oh my God, it's so good.
是的，天哪，这太棒了。
And it's such a great problem that they have to solve and the fact that it takes them that long to get to a hat is really funny.
这是一个他们必须解决的重大问题，而他们花了那么长时间才拿到帽子这一事实真的很有趣。
Yeah.
是的。
No one thinks of hat.
没有人想到帽子。
Can I just say that?
我可以这么说吗？
What made me laugh the hardest also and you always talk about, you know, Jack Handy getting a joke down to one word where Jason just says hat we thought of Native American address before we thought of hat.
是什么让我笑得最厉害，你总是谈论，你知道，杰克汉迪把一个笑话简化为一个词，杰森只是说帽子我们在想到帽子之前就想到了美洲原住民的地址。
Yeah.
是的。
It's real sweet when that the guy with the was he on a lawnmower or wheelbarrow like wheelbarrow or something.
当那个拿着割草机或独轮手推车之类的东西的人时，这真的很甜蜜。
Yeah.
是的。
very convenient gardener.
非常方便的园丁。
But that's also the, there's magic, like it's an enchanted universe, the universe of.
但这也是，有魔法，就像是一个被施了魔法的宇宙，宇宙。
It is, the universe smiled upon them because they did the right thing.
是的，宇宙向他们微笑，因为他们做了正确的事。
They left the bullshit chaos of the idea of what the plan was gonna be.
他们留下了关于计划的想法的混乱。
Yeah.
是的。
C, C aforementioned point of entire series.
C，整个系列的C点。
And then they embraced what moment they were actually in and what their life actually was and the universe gave to me.
然后他们接受了他们实际上所处的时刻，他们的生活实际上是什么以及宇宙给了我什么。
And the end of guitar.
还有吉他的结尾。
Angel gardener who was clearly a ghost.
天使园丁显然是一个幽灵。
I'm surprised Marshall didn't say like, I think this guy was, this is a ghost.
我很惊讶马歇尔没有说，我认为这家伙是，这是一个鬼魂。
I think that's the grandpa.
我想那就是爷爷吧。
This is the grandpa from the barn.
这是谷仓的爷爷。
He took, there we go.
他拿走了，我们走吧。
He left the barn, like Marshall said.
正如马歇尔所说，他离开了谷仓。
He's not gonna just hang on the barn.
他不会只是挂在谷仓上。
Well, also when we filmed this 19 years ago, I had never been married.
嗯，19 年前我们拍摄这个的时候，我还没有结婚。
I had never had a wedding.
我从未举办过婚礼。
My wife and I had a wedding two years ago, just two years ago.
我和妻子两年前举行了婚礼，就在两年前。
And we, it was a winter wedding and it upstayed at this beautiful venue called Cedar Lakes Estate.
我们，这是一场冬季婚礼，并在这个名为雪松湖庄园 (Cedar Lakes Estate) 的美丽场地举办。
And we had everything obviously planned out perfectly.
我们显然把一切都计划得很完美。
and there was a blizzard, a blizzard, like a proper blizzard, and we were supposed to get married outside.
下了一场暴风雪，一场暴风雪，就像一场真正的暴风雪，我们本来应该在外面结婚的。
Now, we didn't know it was gonna be a blizzard, we thought it would be a light flurry, so we decided to keep the wedding outside.
现在，我们不知道会下暴风雪，我们以为会是一阵小雪，所以我们决定在室外举行婚礼。
We got married in a blizzard.
我们在一场暴风雪中结婚了。
Now, the photos are extraordinary, and the video that we got is extraordinary, and people who were at this wedding said, this was one of the most memorable things but one third of the guests were stranded that were not supposed to stay on the property, but they had to find places for everyone to sleep.
现在，这些照片非常出色，我们收到的视频也非常出色，参加这场婚礼的人说，这是最难忘的事情之一，但三分之一的客人被困在不应该留在酒店的地方，但他们必须为每个人找到睡觉的地方。
I mean, it was a chaotic stress-inducing thing that ended up in the last analysis to be perfect and beautiful and just the wedding we wanted and just the wedding we needed and got.
我的意思是，这是一件混乱的、引发压力的事情，但最终分析结果却是完美而美丽的，正是我们想要的婚礼，也是我们需要并得到的婚礼。
But look, people remember a wedding that they had to resort to cannibalism at.
但是你看，人们记得他们不得不在一场婚礼上吃人。
Yeah, that's why the sticks in your head.
是的，这就是为什么你的脑子里有棍子。
Yeah, it wasn't quite the Donner party, but it was close.
是的，这不完全是唐纳派对，但也很接近了。
And no, the venue was incredible.
不，这个场地令人难以置信。
They got people, things to sleep in and toiletries, like everyone was very well taken care of.
他们有人、睡觉的东西和洗漱用品，就像每个人都得到了很好的照顾。
But it was- That's great, it's great.
但它是——那太棒了，太棒了。
You know, we said afterwards that a wedding is a dress rehearsal that is the show.
你知道，我们后来说过，婚礼就是一场彩排，就是一场表演。
Yeah.
是的。
It is not something that you can perfect.
这不是你可以完美的事情。
And in some ways, you wouldn't, you would mistrust a perfect wedding.
在某些方面，你不会，你会怀疑一场完美的婚礼。
It's over-determined.
已经是超定了。
Like weddings where, I remember I had a meditation teacher said, we love children because they're a bundle of mistakes.
就像婚礼一样，我记得有一位冥想老师说过，我们爱孩子，因为他们是一堆错误。
Like if a child came out wearing a tux and speaking perfect English, she'd be like, that's a demon.
就像如果一个孩子穿着燕尾服出来，说一口流利的英语，她会说，那是一个恶魔。
That's a demon child.
那是一个恶魔的孩子。
Like we love seeing them stumble and not, you know, and mispronounce words and say, so there's something about even a wedding where like there's going to be those toasts that you're like, I wish they wouldn't have said that.
就像我们喜欢看到他们跌跌撞撞，而不是，你知道的，发音错误并说，所以即使是一场婚礼，也会有一些你喜欢的祝酒词，我希望他们不会这么说。
There's just so many things about a wedding that are It's perfect chaos.
一场婚礼有太多的事情是完全混乱的。
It's like it's an imperfectly perfect event.
就好像这是一个不完美的事件。
Yeah.
是的。
Yeah, and it's a good exercise in memory too, right?
是的，这也是一个很好的记忆练习，对吧？
Because Marshall and Lily and the whole the show, Future Ted, we don't even see Marshall and Lily's wedding.
因为马歇尔和莉莉以及整个节目《未来的泰德》，我们甚至没有看到马歇尔和莉莉的婚礼。
We spent an entire season talking about Marshall and Lily's wedding, and we breezed through it in a series of quick, farcical cuts, right?
我们花了整整一季的时间来谈论马歇尔和莉莉的婚礼，我们通过一系列快速、滑稽的剪辑轻松地看完了它，对吧？
Right?
正确的？
We see the improvised thing.
我们看到了即兴创作的东西。
The more beautiful improvised thing is what we take the time to see.
更美丽的即兴创作是我们花时间去看的。
And then the finale of the season, we just see the aftermath, the reception, and we are in flashbacks there.
然后到了本季的结局，我们只看到了后果，接待，我们在那里的闪回。
We never really see much of that wedding.
我们从来没有真正看过那场婚礼。
We actually see little glimpses of it later in series.
事实上，我们在后面的系列中几乎看不到它的踪迹。
We go back and we showed some of the other glimpses, I think.
我想，我们回去后还展示了一些其他的一瞥。
But I love that idea, Josh.
但我喜欢这个主意，乔什。
I love that idea of the thing you think it's supposed to be, it's not.
我喜欢这样的想法：你认为它应该是，但事实并非如此。
And that's a lesson.
这就是一个教训。
That is the life lesson of the whole show.
这就是整部剧的人生教训。
And I love that we don't even see the wedding.
我喜欢我们甚至没有看到婚礼。
We have a lot of examples of that on this show.
我们在这个节目中有很多这样的例子。
I loved me and Jordana's wedding, but no less moving was a couple days before the wedding going to City Hall.
我爱我和乔丹娜的婚礼，但同样令人感动的是婚礼前几天前往市政厅。
We got married with our friend, Jacob, who actually introduced us as our witness.
我们和我们的朋友雅各布结婚了，他实际上介绍了我们作为见证人。
And we did it for insurance reasons for something, like we wanted to get her on my insurance.
我们这样做是出于保险原因，比如我们想让她加入我的保险。
But so I got married a couple days before, and just the three of us at City Hall with this officiant, I found it so moving.
但几天前我结婚了，只有我们三个人在市政厅和这位司仪一起，我觉得很感动。
I was like the boil down essence of the thing without any of the pomp and circumstance.
我就像事物的本质，没有任何排场和环境。
It's very similar to this.
与此非常相似。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
And it did take, and also I bet it took a little pressure off of like when that blizzard really started going more, you thought you're like, well, fuck it, we are already married, I think speaking.
这确实需要，而且我敢打赌，当暴风雪真正开始变得更大时，你会觉得你会觉得，好吧，操它，我们已经结婚了，我想，这会减轻一些压力。
And that's the gift that Marshall and Lily gave themselves.
这就是马歇尔和莉莉送给自己的礼物。
Well, I mean, in a way, Ted gave it to them because I think Ted is the one who says, he was the one who suggested it.
嗯，我的意思是，在某种程度上，特德把它给了他们，因为我认为特德是那个说的人，他是提出这个建议的人。
So do it here.
所以在这里做吧。
Do it here.
在这里做。
That's why Ted is, that's why Ted is Ted.
这就是泰德的原因，这就是泰德之所以是泰德的原因。
He said, let's do it here.
他说，我们就在这里吧。
And he was right.
他是对的。
And that's the thing they all remember.
这就是他们都记得的事情。
Yeah, I mean, sometimes he's the no, it has to be like when it's about him.
是的，我的意思是，有时候他是不行的，这必须像关于他的时候一样。
He's like, no, it has to be like this and plan for other people.
他说，不，必须是这样，并为其他人做好计划。
He can really improvise and see it.
他真的可以即兴发挥并看到它。
It's Ted becoming able to do the ladder for himself.
泰德能够自己做梯子了。
That is in a way what we're investigating over nine seasons.
在某种程度上，这就是我们在九个赛季中所调查的内容。
But yeah, what was it?
但是，是的，那是什么？
Lily says, so she, uh, Robin says first lie of the marriage.
莉莉说，所以她，呃，罗宾说了婚姻的第一个谎言。
That was fast.
那很快。
Yeah.
是的。
The smoking she said, did you she kisses him one little package?
她抽着烟说，你亲了他一小包吗？
He goes, did you smoke?
他走了，你抽烟吗？
No, right?
不，对吧？
By the way, he says, did you smoke first lie of the marriage?
顺便说一句，他说，你吸过婚姻的第一个谎言吗？
That was fast.
那很快。
It's a great callback, though, the, um, you know, should we do it in the bathroom?
不过，这是一个很棒的回调，嗯，你知道，我们应该在浴室里做吗？
And please don't.
请不要。
Yes.
是的。
That's a great call back to the to the bunk bed callback, which is a joke from the pilot that we then saw or the earlier in season two.
这是对双层床回调的一个很好的回调，这是我们随后看到的飞行员或第二季早些时候的一个笑话。
We acted on joke from the pilot and now we've called it back.
我们听了飞行员的玩笑，现在我们已经收回了。
So that's the third gift of that one joke from the pilot.
这是飞行员那个笑话的第三个礼物。
It's fantastic, man.
太棒了，伙计。
Can you, you know, use all the Buffalo?
你知道吗，你能用掉所有的水牛吗？
I actually was wondering.
我其实很想知道。
I was like, I don't remember filming that.
我当时想，我不记得拍过那个。
I was like, were those my legs?
我当时想，那是我的腿吗？
I don't know.
我不知道。
I know it was my voice.
我知道那是我的声音。
I have a feeling that you were all in.
我有一种感觉，你们都在。
I was feeling you were all in.
我感觉你们都在。
And they were like, it's a prop toilet.
他们说，这是一个道具厕所。
Who did this?
这是谁干的？
That's an arrested event.
这是一起被捕事件。
That's an arrested development reference.
这是一个停滞的发展参考。
Your book, Josh's method.
你的书，乔希的方法。
He's a method.
他是一个方法。
If he was a good dummy.
如果他是一个好傀儡的话。
That's right.
这是正确的。
Yeah.
是的。
You hire me.
你雇用我。
You better be prepared.
你最好做好准备。
One take.
一拍。
It's like the Mohawk.
就像莫霍克发型一样。
We also had one take for that, for other reasons.
出于其他原因，我们也对此有一个看法。
Welcome back.
欢迎回来。
We are finishing our discussion on episode 21, something borrowed.
我们正在结束对第 21 集的讨论，这是借来的。
Alec, what do you have for us?
亚历克，你有什么要给我们的吗？
Are we still calling this general questions?
我们仍然称之为一般性问题吗？
General questions?
一般问题？
I hope we aren't, because we committed this now.
我希望我们不是，因为我们现在就承诺了这一点。
We do have a couple of questions.
我们确实有几个问题。
I've asked a bunch of them during the show here.
我在这里的演出期间问过很多人。
We have one little silly one.
我们有一个小傻瓜。
I also just want to put on the record that I really felt like Todd should have played the videographer in this show.
我也只是想记录一下，我真的觉得托德应该在这个节目中扮演摄像师。
And I'll tell you why, because I was actually the videographer during this episode.
我会告诉你原因，因为我实际上是这一集的摄像师。
I made a behind the scenes feature, which we're going to talk about in our next episode.
我制作了一个幕后故事，我们将在下一集中讨论它。
Right.
正确的。
At the time, I was like, can't you just put me in like, well, you were already Todd.
当时，我就想，你不能把我也放进去吗，好吧，你已经是托德了。
And I was like, well, maybe Todd is so pissed that that you guys got Van Smoot that I couldn't quite put it together.
我当时想，好吧，也许托德很生气，因为你们得到了范斯穆特，我无法完全把它放在一起。
But it really felt like I was standing with a camera already.
但我真的感觉我已经拿着相机站在那里了。
The one thing Alec we knew about Todd is that he fucking hated these people forgetting the Van Smoot House.
我们对托德了解的亚历克的一件事是，他他妈的讨厌这些人忘记了范斯穆特之家。
Now he's videographing their wedding.
现在他正在拍摄他们的婚礼。
Come on.
快点。
Bridge too far.
桥太远了。
Show some commitment to your character versus just your desire to be on camera.
表现出对你的角色的一些承诺，而不只是你对镜头的渴望。
I just want to look.
我只是想看看。
I still get checked with $46.
我仍然被检查了 46 美元。
It's called integrity every three months.
所谓诚信，每三个月一次。
And I got to half a dinner with it.
我用它吃了半顿晚餐。
Here's you remember there was a bar in the valley called residuals.
这里你还记得山谷里有一家叫残差的酒吧吗？
Do you know where all the checks up on the wall, right?
你知道墙上的所有检查都在哪里吗？
Like one cent thirty five.
就像一分三十五。
Yeah, you could bring in your residual check.
是的，你可以带上你的剩余支票。
I think if it was under five dollars or ten dollars, yeah, yeah, you could exchange it for a drink and they would put the check on the wall.
我想如果它低于五美元或十美元，是的，是的，你可以用它换一杯饮料，他们会把支票贴在墙上。
I think that I think that's still there.
我想我认为那仍然存在。
That's amazing.
太棒了。
I get I get one cent from Showtime.
我从 Showtime 得到一分钱。
I get the one cent residuals tavern, Still going, residuals tavern, studio city opens today.
我拿到一毛钱残品酒馆，还在继续，残品酒馆，影城今天开业。
Opens at noon today.
今天中午开门。
All right, go bring your residuals.
好吧，带上你的残渣吧。
Yeah, yeah.
是啊是啊。
Go in there with your $46 check.
带着你的 46 美元支票进去。
I know I was in the cold open of a Showtime show and I get a one set check for that.
我知道我在 Showtime 演出中处于冷场，因此我得到了一套检查。
All right, well, you, I think any residual gets you a drink now.
好吧，好吧，你，我想现在有任何残留物都可以让你喝一杯。
I thought that we're now just making up with their policy.
我以为我们现在只是在弥补他们的政策。
And I don't know if that's true.
我不知道这是不是真的。
They're like, that's not how it works.
他们就像，事情不是这样的。
Get out of here.
离开这里。
Stop saying we're going to be seated for residuals.
别再说我们要为剩下的人安排座位了。
Wait, what's the question?
等等，问题是什么？
We have a lot of folks on Instagram and, and, and on our website who are just like, they're so happy this podcast exists because they do have these like nitty gritty detail questions and they're like, oh my God, I get to actually ask this.
我们在 Instagram 和我们的网站上有很多人，他们很高兴这个播客的存在，因为他们确实有这些细节问题，他们就像，天哪，我真的可以问这个。
So this is not profound, but Craig, Eddie underscore did that asks, says, I have a question that has burdened me for years.
所以这并不深刻，但埃迪强调克雷格确实问了，说，我有一个多年来一直困扰我的问题。
In this episode, we discovered that Scooter's real name is Bill, and it's not just a minor detail.
在这一集中，我们发现Scooter的真名是Bill，这不仅仅是一个小细节。
There's a whole running joke around it, but later in season eight, we discover that his name is Jeff.
关于它有一个完整的笑话，但在第八季后期，我们发现他的名字叫杰夫。
Oh, no.
哦，不。
Was this a mistake or is there some sort of story behind it?
这是一个错误还是背后有什么故事？
It would be a flat out mistake.
这将是一个彻头彻尾的错误。
This is the first thing.
这是第一件事。
This is how I find out.
我就是这样发现的。
I enjoy saying that when it's possible, so it's a good way to say it.
我喜欢在可能的情况下这么说，所以这是一个很好的表达方式。
This is how I find out.
我就是这样发现的。
if we did that, we fucked it up.
如果我们这样做了，我们就搞砸了。
Oh my God.
我的天啊。
Is that for sure true?
这确定是真的吗？
Can we get some verification with some evidence?
我们可以通过一些证据来验证吗？
And I've asked him for it.
我已经问过他了。
I've asked him for the evidence.
我已经向他要证据了。
So while we're doing some other stuff, I'm gonna check if he has responded to me.
因此，当我们在做其他事情时，我会检查他是否回复了我。
Of all things to fuck up, to get David Berka, Neil's actual husband's character's name wrong.
最糟糕的是，把尼尔真正丈夫的角色名字大卫·伯卡(David Berka)弄错。
What did, like, of all the ones to fuck up?
所有那些搞砸的人到底做了什么？
I will say though, if I was in the writer's room and it was a vote between Bill and Jeff, Scooter seems like a Jeff more than a bill.
不过我要说的是，如果我在编剧的房间里，这是比尔和杰夫之间的投票，那么斯库特看起来更像是杰夫而不是法案。
I don't know how, but I don't know why, but you're right.
我不知道怎么做，也不知道为什么，但你是对的。
So now it's true.
所以现在这是真的。
I hope we didn't fuck that up.
我希望我们没有把事情搞砸。
But if we did, boy, you know, me a kalpa.
但如果我们这样做了，孩子，你知道，我就一个劫了。
All right.
好的。
Or maybe it's just that old, no, no, no.
或者也许它只是那么旧，不，不，不。
It's that Ted in 2030.
这就是 2030 年的泰德。
Oh, yeah, he forgets.
哦，是的，他忘记了。
Yeah, it's a lapse in memory.
是的，这是记忆失误。
That's our get out of jail free comments.
这就是我们出狱后的自由评论。
Okay, so yeah, we were just trying to make it the real thing.
好吧，是的，我们只是想让它成为真实的东西。
In 2030, how you don't remember who wins the name anymore.
到了 2030 年，你已经不记得谁赢得了这个名字。
Phew, saved it.
唷，救了。
By the way, Alec, I just realized Todd could have been in the episode because Todd could have been fucking up the videography on purpose because he's their enemy and that would have been...
顺便说一句，亚历克，我刚刚意识到托德可能会出现在这一集中，因为托德可能故意搞砸了录像，因为他是他们的敌人，那会是……
He's a saboteur.
他是一个破坏者。
So I'm gonna go, hey, what am I saying?
所以我要走了，嘿，我在说什么？
I'm deeply sorry, you're right, I'm wrong.
我深感抱歉，你是对的，我错了。
You know what?
你知道吗？
This whole thing, I fucked everything up.
这整件事，我把一切都搞砸了。
I fucked Scooter's name up, I fucked that up.
我搞砸了斯库特的名字，我搞砸了。
Look, you owe me $46.
听着，你欠我 46 美元。
We got a great letter, Josh, this one came to you.
我们收到一封很棒的信，乔什，这封信是写给你的。
Yeah, yeah, yeah, a wonderful letter that I received that I asked if we could read on the air, and he said, sure, he would be honored.
是的，是的，是的，我收到了一封很棒的信，我问我们是否可以在广播中阅读，他说，当然，他会很荣幸。
Also, if you would like to send us a letter about your relationship to the show, how it's affected you and what it's meant to you over the years, or if you want to drop us a voice note that maybe we could read at the or play at the beginning of the show, go to our square space created website energy how we made your mother dot com h w w m y m h dot m y m dot com go to contact and it should be pretty clear from there because square space makes everything pretty clear and Alec did a great job with that here is today's letter hi Josh I wanted to say thank you.
另外，如果您想向我们发送一封信，介绍您与该节目的关系，这些年来它对您有何影响以及它对您意味着什么，或者如果您想给我们留言，也许我们可以在节目开始时阅读或播放，请访问我们的 Square Space 创建网站 energy how we made your mother dot com h w w m y m h dot m y m dot com 去联系，从那里应该很清楚，因为方形空间使一切都非常清晰和亚历克（Alec）做得很好，这是今天的信，嗨乔希（Josh），我想说谢谢你。
I watched liberal arts in 2015, that's a movie I wrote and directed, and recommended it to my friends.
2015年我看了文科，那是我自编自导的电影，推荐给了朋友。
When they saw the movie, they went, that's Ted Mosby Shantanu, and I had no idea who that was.
当他们看到这部电影时，他们说那是泰德·莫斯比·山塔努，但我不知道那是谁。
After about a year of wondering whether I should even start watching movies or TV shows, I was completely new to cinema.
在考虑是否应该开始看电影或电视节目大约一年后，我对电影完全陌生了。
I thought, you know what?
我想，你知道吗？
Let's give how I met your mother a try.
让我们尝试一下我是如何认识你母亲的。
All caps hooked.
所有大写都钩住了。
It was unbelievable.
这太令人难以置信了。
I'd never seen someone disguise such as serious drama as a comedy like that.
我从来没有见过有人把严肃的戏剧伪装成这样的喜剧。
After the show ended, I watched the cast interviews, the bloopers, basically anything I could find.
演出结束后，我看了演员采访、花絮，基本上是我能找到的任何东西。
That's when I started hearing your thoughts on fame, happiness, and humanity.
从那时起，我开始听到你对名誉、幸福和人性的想法。
Apart from my dad, I have two male role models.
除了我父亲之外，我还有两个男性榜样。
One is you, and the other is Maddie Healy from the 1975.
一个是你，另一个是 1975 年的 Maddie Healy。
Thank you for showing me that my thoughts are not who I am.
谢谢你让我知道我的想法并不代表我是谁。
My actions aren't.
我的行动不是。
I had to limit my social media usage to two days a month to really live by that.
我必须将社交媒体的使用限制在每月两天，才能真正过上这样的生活。
Watching the world split itself into left versus right, I've realized it's better for me to just shut up, do my job, and take care of the people around me.
看着世界分裂成左派和右派，我意识到对我来说最好闭嘴，做好我的工作，照顾周围的人。
I want my music, the art I'm building to not be about that divide.
我希望我的音乐、我正在创作的艺术不与这种鸿沟有关。
I want it to be for everyone.
我希望它适合所有人。
I now spend a lot of effort trying to understand someone's intent before I say something.
现在，我在说话之前会花很多精力试图理解某人的意图。
It's tough to do in my head, but I'll be okay.
这对我来说很难做到，但我会没事的。
I know.
我知道。
Happy, thank you more, please, Shuntan.
开心，更谢谢你，顺坦。
Thanks for that.
谢谢你。
That's lovely.
太可爱了。
That's wonderful.
太棒了。
You know, I really love this observation, a serious drama disguised as a comedy.
你知道，我真的很喜欢这个观察，一部伪装成喜剧的严肃戏剧。
That's the show.
这就是节目。
I thought that was a really wonderful observation.
我认为这是一个非常精彩的观察。
Yeah.
是的。
Me too.
我也是。
I love that way of framing it.
我喜欢这种框架方式。
That's how we think of it.
我们就是这么想的。
And that's the Trojan horse we were sneaking on to CBS in 2005 among a lot of other sitcoms or sitcoms.
这就是 2005 年我们在 CBS 的许多其他情景喜剧或情景喜剧中偷偷植入的特洛伊木马。
I would say.
我会说。
I don't even mean that as an insult.
我什至没有侮辱的意思。
different tones, and we were kind of, we were our own little thing, and that's what we were, so thanks for seeing it.
不同的语气，我们是我们自己的小东西，这就是我们，所以感谢您看到它。
Yeah, thanks so much.
是的，非常感谢。
I am guilty, please equip me, all sins are forgiven, in New York City.
我有罪，请装备我，所有的罪孽都被宽恕，在纽约。
How we made your mother is hosted and executive produced by Josh Radner and Craig Thomas, and is presented and distributed by the Office Ladies Network and Odyssey.
《我们如何造就你的母亲》由乔什·拉德纳 (Josh Radner) 和克雷格·托马斯 (Craig Thomas) 主持并监制，并由 Office Ladies Network 和 Odyssey 出品和发行。
This episode is also executive produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey.
本集还由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛担任执行制作。
The show is produced and edited by me, Alec Lev, and our co-producer is Doug Matica.
该节目由我 Alec Lev 制作和编辑，我们的联合制作人是 Doug Matica。
Our audio producer and mixer is Alex Reeves at Point of Blue Studios.
我们的音频制作人和混音师是 Point of Blue Studios 的 Alex Reeves。
Our digital content producer, aka Gen Z Master, is Emily Blumberg.
我们的数字内容制作人，又名 Z 世代大师，是 Emily Blumberg。
Artwork by John Morrow.
约翰·莫罗的艺术作品。
Please follow, rate and review the show on Apple Podcasts or your podcast player of choice.
请在 Apple 播客或您选择的播客播放器上关注、评分和评论该节目。
It really does help the show.
对节目确实有帮助。
Our theme song is New York City by our own Josh Radner with additional music by Craig Thomas and Andrew Majuski.
我们的主题曲是我们自己的 Josh Radner 创作的《New York City》，其他音乐由 Craig Thomas 和 Andrew Majuski 创作。
Special thanks to Lola Kennedy and Elliot Connors.
特别感谢洛拉·肯尼迪和埃利奥特·康纳斯。
Visit HowWeMajorMother.com to learn more and click on the contact page to send us an email or a voice message.
请访问 HowWeMajorMother.com 了解更多信息，然后单击联系页面向我们发送电子邮件或语音消息。
Your stories and questions are an important part of the show.
您的故事和问题是节目的重要组成部分。
Subscribe to Josh Radner's newsletters on Substack and check out his music and everything else at joshradner.com.
在 Substack 上订阅 Josh Radner 的时事通讯，并在 joshradner.com 上查看他的音乐和其他所有内容。
Order Craig Thomas' debut novel, That's Not How It Happened, Wherever Books Are Sold, and check out his other published writings at CraigThomasWriter.com.
订购克雷格·托马斯的处女作《事情不是这样发生的》、《无论书在哪里》，并在 CraigThomasWriter.com 上查看他出版的其他作品。
And you can subscribe to my own Dead Fathers Society, also on Substack.
你也可以在 Substack 上订阅我自己的 Dead Fathers Society。
To learn more about how you make a difference, this shows ongoing campaign, to raise money for congenital pediatric heart disease research, check out the Make a Difference tab at the top of our website.
要了解有关如何做出改变的更多信息，这显示了正在进行的为先天性儿科心脏病研究筹集资金的活动，请查看我们网站顶部的“做出改变”选项卡。
People will, in fact, dance.
事实上，人们会跳舞。